>> Laura: HILLARY CLINTON
SEEMS TO THINK SHE'S NOT RUNNING
IN 2020 BUT SHE IS RUNNING WITH
THE RACE CARD.
>> I WAS THE FIRST PERSON WHO
RAN FOR PRESIDENT WITHOUT THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT AND I WILL TELL YOU IT MAKES
A REALLY BIG DIFFERENCE.
IT MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
WISCONSIN WHERE THE BEST STUDIES
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE SAID
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 40 AND 80,000
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THE
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THP
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THL
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THS
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THB
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THC
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THU
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THE
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THO
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THF
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THT
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THE
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THC
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THL
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY FROM THR
OF THEIR SKIN.
>> Laura: GUESS WHAT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" GAVE HER
FOUR PINOCCHIOS FOR THAT BLATANT
LIE.
80,000 PEOPLE TURNED AWAY FROM
POLLS?
JOINING ME NOW, RENOWNED
ECONOMIST, OLD FRIEND TOM
SOWELL, SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
HOOVER INSTITUTION, AUTHOR OF
THE PHENOMENAL BOOK
"DISCRIMINATION IN DISPARITIES,"
NOW OUT IN A REVISED AND
ENLARGED EDITION, TOM, THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
WHY IS HILLARY SAYING THAT?
I THINK SHE KNOWS IT'S NOT TRUE.
SO WHY?
>> BECAUSE SHE THINKS IT WILL
GET HER SOME VOTES.
THAT'S THE REASON POLITICIANS
SAY A LOT OF THINGS AND ARE NOT
TRUE.
>> Laura: HILLARY CLINTON, SO
MANY OTHERS ARE ARE NOW TALKING
ABOUT REPARATIONS.
TRUMP IS A RACIST.
IT'S RACE, RACE, RACE,
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS RACIST.
THE RACE WORD IS A CONSTANT.
IT'S LIKE ABORTION AND RACE IN
TODAY'S DEMOCRAT PARTY.
>> IT IS, AND I HAVE A FEELING
THAT MANY AMERICANS WOULD JUST
AS SOON NOT HEAR ANY MORE ABOUT
RACE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE FOR WHOM THIS
IS THEIR TICKET TO WHATEVER
RACKET THEY ARE RUNNING,
INCLUDING THE POLITICAL RACKET.
IT'S TRAGIC.
WHAT'S TRAGIC IS THERE SO MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO SIMPLY
RESPOND TO WORDS RATHER THAN ASK
THEMSELVES, IS WHAT THIS PERSON
SAYS TRUE?
HOW CAN I CHECK IT AND SO ON.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THAT
WITH THE JUSSIE SMOLLETT CASE IN
CHICAGO AND NOW WE HAVE THIS
R. KELLY GUY WHO WAS ACCUSED
OF --
R. KELLY IS NOT FOCUSING ON RACE
BUT THE SMOLLETT CASE BECAME ONE
ABOUT RACE.
IT WAS NOVELS LIKE THERE WERE
CERTAIN PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
WERE DISAPPOINTED WHEN IT SEEMS
LIKE THIS THING WITH A BIG HOAX.
THEY WANTED THIS TO BE A RACIAL
INCIDENT, RACIAL HATE CRIME
REINFORCING THE STEREOTYPES THAT
THIS IS WHAT'S WRONG WITH
SOCIETY TODAY.
THE OVERRIDING PROBLEM IN
SOCIETY TODAY IS ONE OF RACE.
TOM.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE IN
FOOTBALL.
THEY ARE TO RUN THAT PLAY UNTIL
SOMEONE FINDS A WAY TO STOP IT.
AS LONG AS IT PAYS OFF, THEY'RE
GOING TO KEEP DOING IT.
WHAT'S PAINFUL TO ME IS HOW FEW
PEOPLE THERE ARE TODAY WHO
BOTHER TO CHECK OUT THE FACTS.
IN MANY CASES, JUST THE SMALLEST
EFFORT OF CHECKING OUT THE FACTS
WOULD COST SO MANY OF THESE
THINGS TO FALL APART.
WE HAVE A WHOLE HISTORY OF THIS,
GOING BACK TO A WOMAN IN THE
19-SOMETHING AND THEN ANOTHER
CASE.
ANY NUMBER OF THESE THINGS.
AS LONG AS THEY KEEP SUCCEEDING
POLITICALLY, THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO RUN THAT PLAY.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD DO WELL TO
MAKE, LIKE MONTHLY TRIPS TO
UNDERSERVED, MORE
UNDERPRIVILEGED AREAS OR TO
TRADITIONALLY BLACK COLLEGES,
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, WHERE HE
CAN JUST TALK ABOUT WISE
POLICIES ARE WORKING ON WHY THE
ECONOMY IS GROWING
OPPORTUNITIES, JOBS, GREATER
EMPLOYMENT ET CETERA.
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THAT HE DO
THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK THE VENUE
MATTERS THAT MUCH.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME THOUGHTFUL
NOTIONS ABOUT HOW FREE MARKETS
AND OTHER KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE DIFFERENT FROM ONE ARE
NORMALLY HEARD, HOW THOSE THINGS
IMPACT.
I DON'T SEE ANY SIGN OF THAT OF
ANY SIGNIFICANCE UNFORTUNATELY
FROM THE REPUBLICANS.
I NEVER CEASE TO BE AMAZED AT
HOW MANY OPPORTUNITIES THEY LET
GO BY.
RIGHT NOW FOR EXAMPLE, DEMOCRATS
AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE LIGHTING
UP TO STOP CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM
EXPANDING, TRYING TO CUT BACK ON
THEM.
MANY OF THEM ARE THE VERY
SCHOOLS THAT ARE MOST
SUCCESSFUL, THEY ARE THE ONES
THEY ARE ZEROING IN ON, PLACES
LIKE SUCCESS ACADEMY OR CHIP
SCHOOLS.
THE DEMOCRATS, AND UNDERSTAND
THEY HAVE TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THEY ARE BEHOLDEN TO THE
TEACHERS UNIONS.
BUT WHY THE REPUBLICANS DON'T
SAY ANYTHING ABOUT IT, THAT'S
WHAT BAFFLES ME.
>> Laura: TRULY PRO-CHOICE
INITIATIVES THAT ACTUALLY HELP
INDIVIDUALS AND SO I'M JUST
FOCUSING ON BLOCKS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
DR. SOWELL, AOC, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, SHE HAS SPOKEN A
LOT ABOUT SOCIALISM AND BEING A
DEMOCRAT SOCIALIST.
SHE IS A YOUNG PERSON, 28 YEARS
OLD.
SHE IS REPRESENTING A DECENT
CHUNK OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
TODAY.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FOR YOU
AND HAVE YOU REACT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHEN MILLENNIALS TALK ABOUT
CONCEPTS LIKE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISM, WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THESE KIND OF RED SCARE
BOGEYMAN.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
SINGLE-PAYER HEALTH CARE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT TUITION
FREE PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A LIVING
WAGE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT GUARANTEED
BASIC LEVELS OF DIGNITY.
>> Laura: IT SOUNDS GOOD TO A
LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE, AND THE
FOCUS GROUP FROM CNN WE JUST
ALLUDED TO, THEY SEEM VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THESE CONCEPTS.
WHAT ARE REPUBLICANS NOT DOING?
>> THE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
SAYING ANYTHING THAT I'VE HEARD.
OF COURSE ALL THESE THINGS SOUND
WONDERFUL.
IT'S JUST THAT WE NOW HAVE MORE
THAN HALF A CENTURY OF KNOWLEDG
KNOWLEDGE, A TRACK RECORD OF
THESE KINDS OF IDEAS BEING PUT
INTO PRACTICE IN COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD AND FAILING
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
NOT MERELY FAILING BUT MAKING
THINGS WORSE THAN THEY WERE
BEFORE.
VENEZUELA IS THE CLASSIC CASE,
AND YET DURING THE WHOLE PERIOD
WHEN PEOPLE ARE STARVING IN
VENEZUELA UNDER SOCIALISM, THE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE, RIGHT OUT OF
OUR COLLEGES, ARE FLOCKING TO
BERNIE SANDERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
JUDGING BY HIS WORDS AND HOW
WONDERFUL IT SOUNDS AND NOT BY
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU TRY TO PUT
THOSE NOTIONS INTO PRACTICE.
AS HAS BEEN TRIED AGAIN,
COUNTRIES IN EUROPE, ASIA,
AFRICA.
>> Laura: FAILED EVERYWHERE.
[LAUGHS]
THE WORST REPEAT FAILED
EXPERIMENT WE'VE EVER SEEN.
DR. TOM SOWELL, IT IS SO GREAT
TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.